everyone knows about the Fibonacci
numbers 1:1 and then I add those two
together to get to them 3 5 8 what would
happen if instead I start with three
numbers and now I'm going to add all
three together so that gives me three
and I'm now going to add these three
together that's gonna give me five and
then these three together that's going
to give me nine and then I'm gonna get
nine five and three 17 and we're gonna
get a different sequence of numbers oh
it's a bit like the Fibonacci but it's
got three instead of two so it's called
the Trib inochi numbers let's call this
and and so this is that ribbon Archie TN
and you have that F n 1 divided by F n
goes to the golden ratio so we can also
do the same thing with the Trib annachi
numbers but they go to what's called at
ribbon achi constant with the Fibonacci
numbers one of the ways we can sort of
think about what how they're going to
end up is say well let's start this one
X x squared + x squared was equal to the
two previous ones together so here this
is x squared is equal to X plus 1 here
we're adding the three previous terms so
we get 1x x squared this term is going
to be the sum of all three so it's X
cubed and now we have X cubed is equal
to x squared plus X plus one and so
that's a polynomial whilst I can
reasonably well solve quadratics cubics
have a far more messy to solve so I'm
going to get a calculator to do that
so this gives us one point eight three
nine two nine and that's gonna trip an
Archie constant tripping Archie constant
I'm assuming there's a four Bonacci
constant and a fire Bonacci they're
called the n Bonacci z' and so here I've
got an interesting shape it's got a a
fractal boundary going around it well
it's got a nice property to it so I've
got this style here and this is the same
shape but a little bit smaller and then
I've got again the same shape but
smaller the edges of these I can find it
I have to get them the right way up and
there we go so the edges are such so
this shape at different sizes actually
fits onto itself and that means that
these edges might must either be
straight lines which they're clearly not
or fractal it's not a fractal itself but
the boundary is a fractal
so now I will take a third shape and put
them there and magically I have my same
shape these are three sizes of this one
shape and when I put those three
together I get the same okay if this one
scales up to this one this one scales up
to this one and then this one scales up
to the whole thing I can take this one
step further so what I've done here is
make a larger version of this object so
this piece here becomes this tile here
and then this tile here is replaced by
the whole piece here it's the the three
tiles if I rotate this there you see
that this is just these three titles so
now we could imagine doing this another
time and another time we can get larger
and larger regions we could ask what how
many tiles am I going to have in them
well this pattern is made up of one of
the smallest tiles one of the medium
tiles and one of the large tiles this is
made up of
one medium one large and then one of the
scale size beyond large which itself is
made up of one small one medium and one
large and when I go into the next step
up I'm gonna have one copy of this one
copy of this and then one additional so
at each stage I'm going to take the
three previous pieces put them together
to get the next one up and so what are
we going to have well it's back over
here I have my 1 1 1 I put those
together so I get 3 1 1 and 3 gives me
my 5 the next one up is going to be my 5
my 3 and my 1 which is going to give me
9 and so on like that so this shape is
called the Rousey fractal and it was
found by Gerald Rousey the interest is
sort of studying how matrices act on
three-dimensional space and there's a
lot of nice theory for how for certain
properties of how matrices act on
two-dimensional space especially a
matrix which has one expansion and one
contraction what that will do is you
have up these things called eigenvectors
and you pull down in one direction and
you expand so that everything gets
squashed down and pulled up there's a
whole theory in that called markov
partitions which have basically have
nice properties as you get pulled down
and smeared out you can turn that into a
nice periodic product and what rousey
asks well what about for the the cubic
case when we're dealing with
three-dimensional space so the specific
matrix you're studying here has as one
of its eigenvalues this number the Trib
inari constant and so because the Trib
Renacci constant is turning up in the
thing you're trying to study that's how
it cut turns out in these these tiles
and the golden ratio and Fibonacci
numbers are really important in the
study of the two-dimensional markov
partitions and so when you grow up to
three dimensions you have to deal with
cubic things it's quite natural it's
sort of almost
the ancient Greeks who will who felt
that a cubic number really was a cube so
they didn't
some people say they didn't even believe
in fourth powers when you're dealing
with three dimensions you naturally have
cubic stuff do they exist in sunflowers
and things like that they don't exist in
nature in the way that they just like
the Fibonacci isn't quite as popular by
their nature as is meant to be and the
only place beyond this that I know of
them is an object called the snub cube
which is quite an attractive little
polyhedron
just a reminder that there's now a
numberphile podcast have you had a
listen yet this is what it looks like on
your podcast apps just search for
numberphile and if you haven't got into
this whole podcasting thing that you
still want to have a listen I am putting
the episodes on the number file to
YouTube channel there are links on the
screen and in the description